We are going to destroy the night king in his army and we'll do it together
Promise me
Hey, everybody, so we learned the title of the game of thrones finale is the dragon in the wolf very big connotations
So I believe that it refers to a couple specific things, but it also has broader implications for the narrative
So it always works really well when they're talking about two specific people like Jon and Daenerys
But it also works for a lot of the other storylines too like you have
winterfell in the night King the wolf in the undead Dragon
So there's just gonna be a breakdown a lot of the symbolism and meaning in this because there have been a lot of previous
Episodes where you have two big houses?
Like the wolf and the lion or the lion in the rose so based on the events of some of those other
Episodes in the way, they made those titles there are some heavy implications for stuff that's going to be happening in the finale
So if you're finding me for the first time it is the final episode
But I will be doing videos during the off season there'll be all kinds of book stuff and season 8 happening next year
So be sure to subscribe to get everything
But just starting on the surface level the dragon and the wolf title really is just talking about Jon and Daenerys
And there's this interesting quote from way back during season 1 when George art Martin was still
heavily involved in the development of the TV show
So when you think of the series as a whole a song of ice and fire that's its true
Name people just call it game of thrones because that's what the TV show is called it has a number of different meanings
But when you're talking about characters it really just refers to two people and really what it is is this giant Sprawling?
Series with a bunch of awesome characters, but at its core
It's still just about the coming together of these two people in
Breaking the wheel as Daenerys has said on the TV show
So George are Martin back during the first season when he was still really involved with the development of the show was walking around in
A lot of the directors were getting into the series and learning about all these characters and said you know there's all these interesting people
That are rising up in like ned stark is the biggest character of season 1 so people thought that they were building the show around
Sean Bean until you get to the end of the season and find out nope
It's not about him Martin was walking around while this was happening in responding. Oh, you know
There's all this stuff going on, but it's really about Jon and Daenerys coming together way back during season 1
It's just that you have to get through the first couple of seasons to start caring about these characters because Jon and Daenerys
aren't that big in the first couple of seasons like Daenerys steps out of the fire at the end of season one and
Suddenly you're like holy crap but still for the first couple of seasons
She was kind of being led around by her entourage, sir Jorah was a much bigger character compared to her now
He's kind of gotten pushed to the side a little bit and she's a much bigger deal so you see how they sort of become
the Center of Their own
Universes is they slowly come together as they have in season seven
There was a theory really early on that daenerys might become one of the big villains of the series it still fits with the motif
of a song of ice and fire there's just too many steps I think to get to the point where she actually turns into a
real villain because the TV show is just beating us in the face with Cersei going off the deep end in becoming the
Actual villain of season 8 because as we're talking about the finale
something changed during episode 6 about the war for the Dawn
This isn't a minor thing so previously we have this hundred thousand strong army of the dead
We have to learn how to fight them we need all this dragonglass
We need to band together so that we have the right tools and just physically enough people to fight against them
But the big change to the rules in the last episode is that now you don't have to go around and kill every single white
You just need to kill the one that created them
So it's like killing vampires you killed the head vampire the other vampires that it created. Go away, too
So that's sort of another
Conversation about killing the night King and ending the war for the dawn
Because now you just need somebody to gank the night king who is somebody that's capable of doing that just keep your eyes peeled on
Arya stark we need another terrible tyrion plan
but because the title of the episode is the dragon and the wolf
Thematically is focusing more on a song of ice and fire the bigger themes in these two specific characters
So anything else any other storyline is sort of ancillary it's like they have to wrap things up because it's the finale even though
They're focusing mostly on these two big ideas going a layer deeper
There's another big storyline that they need to bring to a head - and that's the truth of Jon
Snow's parentage, so we already learned from Gilly that jon
snow is the
Legitimate son of Rhaegar and LyAnna because they got married and so that throws a lot of the succession into question even though Jon snow
Doesn't want the iron throne, but because of the way the TV show reveals information like it'll drop some clues
Then it'll make something really clear they have to pay off that Ghillie bomb
So obviously the dragon and the wolf in the title probably also refers to Rhaegar targaryen
and lyAnna stark in the book she was referred to as the she-wolf of
Winterfell which is sort of a way to describe her family heritage as well as her disposition
she was fierce and wild like a wolf you may have heard the story about the knight of the laughing tree about how a
Mystery Knight with a tree as its crest stood up for Howland reed when he was being put upon by a bunch of other knights
If they pay that off on a TV show we can talk a little more about it
But it's just another story that adds more
Context that shows her in a really badass light so she was not somebody to be kidnapped by Rhaegar targaryen
She might have even been able to fight him off even though
He was a very good fighter
People point to that moment between John and Daenerys where he says I'm not happy about the things that I'm good at which is killing
people
Barristan selmy said the same thing about Rhaegar
He may not have been the absolute best sword in the kingdom
But he was a proven badass so they need to pay off the idea that they were in love
Ran off in Pergolas bomb he set aside, Elia Martell who couldn't give him that third child the song of ice and fire
Married LyAnna stark and then gave birth to the prince who he thought was promised
We're all kind of sitting on the edge of our chair
Just waiting to see something that will confirm this how cool. It's gonna be so however they cap it off
We can pick it apart, but whatever's going on in the finale remember
It's all about the story itself is about the dragon in the wolf the song of ice and fire
So you have a lot of really interesting characters, but really the story is just about two people and two big ideas
But you know on the converse
It's nice to think of the dragon and the wolf as the stuff that's happening at winterfell in the coming of the night king who?
Is riding the Dragon?
I know a lot of people are still going on and on about the idea that bran stark is somehow the night king I do
Not believe that theory and there's actually been this photo
That's been circulating so I wanted to address that in this video the thing that you're looking at here is actually a photoshop job
So the necklace that they're wearing that's the same the one that brans wearing is the photoshop job
There's no original photo with him wearing this so someone took this necklace off the night king pick and just
Photoshopped it on to brand that's not something that actually appears during this series
So I do not believe that bran is the night King
but what will happen is is is there's been a lot of
Potholes this season that have given rise to a lot of big theories
So I'll try to keep that in mind when I do my finale video because I'm sure it'll happen again
There'll be some moment that doesn't totally make sense, and there'll be some big fan. Theory that'll come out of it
That's just part of the fun though theories that don't pan out
But leave all your favorite dragon in the wolf finale theories in the comments below even if you don't think that they'll come true
It's sort of in that same vein I know a lot of people have pointed to the other
titles like the lion in the rose which was the purple wedding during season 4 and say that whenever they have titles like this with
Two big ideas coming together one of them ends up dying like the lion VS.
the Rose the Lion Joffrey ended up dying
I don't think the metaphor totally works like it doesn't completely hold up because Daenerys isn't Gonna Die Jon
Snow isn't gonna Die and like I said the title mostly refers to them
but if you also think of it as referring to rhaegar and lyAnna
I guess rhaegar did die so you could say in a roundabout way that one of the things in the title winds up dying but
He didn't die til the trident which is much later
And I'm not expecting to see any trident stuff or rhaegar actually dying till the final season there is a new round of that
Hbo now giveaway going on all you have to do to enter is just be a subscriber leave a comment on this video there'll be
More mythology stuff that I'll post before the finale so yeah special requests
Just leave them in the comments below
but click here for my finale
Trailer video
And you can click here to learn more about the history of Rhaegar and lyAnna the stuff that they actually did thank you so much
For watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight